data science teams work in diverse
technical environments with many data
sources coding tools computational
requirements and client expectations for
data products
having this work spread across multiple
systems creates inefficient work silos
and introduces critical gaps in security
our studio workbench addresses all of
this by providing it the ability to
manage and scale data ingestion analysis
and data product creation securely all
from one place while providing data
scientists the ability to collaborate on
r and python projects
whether rstudio with its ability to run
multiple versions of r in different
sessions or jupyter lab or jupyter
notebooks or vs code each with the
option of running pre-configured data
connectors requesting compute resources
and providing the ability to collaborate
within a shared environment
if they choose to use the rstudio ide
team members can share projects and
track work in real time
helping to keep up with changes and
supporting best practices for code
review which ultimately allows data
science leaders to build happy and
effective teams while delivering value
to their stakeholders
using our studio workbench the data
science team can create reports
dashboards and interactive applications
for the organization's decision makers
which can be hosted on platforms such as
rstudio connect
by moving work from the local laptop and
onto our studio workbench users can
quickly authenticate and spin up the
coding environment of their choice for
either r or python providing easy access
to pre-configured data connectors like
snowflake mongodb and spark just to name
a few
[Music]
your team can also request critical
compute resources that they won't likely
have access to on local systems with
different user or group profiles for
default and max resource usage which
helps to control cost
our studio workbench makes it easier for
teams to work together by providing a
standardized set of installed software
which helps ensure that data science
work is reproducible between team
members and integration with git
supports collaboration and code
governance across coding environments
our studio workbench enable your team to
build great data science products
[Music]